noch einmal zu henrik schräg wir haben
gehört dass der us-präsident
experimentelle vollkommen neue und noch
nicht zugelassene medikamente bekommen
hat unter anderem rem diese wir aber
auch ein weiteres medikament das nur bei
schweren verläufen gegeben wird worauf
deutet das hin dass man dem
us-präsidenten dieses rem diese wir gibt
ja das überraschende daran eigentlich
waren zwei dinge in der brandung einmal
dass eine regeneration bekommen hat das
ist ein antikörper behandlung die
derzeit in einer klinischen studie
richtet hinten ist bei dieser auch bei
diesem bitte handelte sich eine zum 2
ganzen körper
die sehr starke wirkungen gegen das neue
monat wir uns haben und in klinischen
studien sehr gut aussehen also der gute
wirkung zeigen aber sie sind wie gesagt
noch nicht zugelassen und daher ist es
unmöglich dass so was bereits einige
setzen zusätzlich neben registriert was
auch in leichter form erleichterungen
eingesetzt wird liegt aber auch noch ex
mieter sohn das ist ein port des wohn
und das ist meistens dann gegeben
zumindest in deutschland aber auch in
den usa beim größten wo eine
sauerstofftherapie aber auch wird
recovery zeit und gezeigt dass das einen
positiven einfluss auf die union hat was
aber darauf deutet dass er doch da auch
extern sauerstoff angewiesen ist zurzeit